Paul you had the enviable task of
reading the entire there you go you've
managed to do you printed out every page
of it so far from what you've been able
to glean tell us what is in there and
what do we need to know well I think we
see the predictable end result of
Justice Kennedy's years long journey
using the Constitution's due process and
equal protection clauses to extend the
right to marry to same-sex couples the
same as heterosexual couples and you see
a fairly predictable pushback from the
for more conservative members of the
court saying that it's fine with us if
legislators want to extend this right to
same-sex couples but this is not the
judiciary's work to do and Chief Justice
Roberts in the main dissent even went so
far as to say look if you're in favor of
gay marriage
terrific celebrate today in a very
expansive sense he said it's a wonderful
day for you but don't celebrate the
Constitution because the Constitution
should not have accomplished this this
was a task for democracy to accomplish
for lawmakers well speaking of lawmakers
let's bring up what President Obama has
tweeted now following the Supreme Court
decision he tweeted out shortly today's
a big step in our march toward equality
gay and lesbian couples now have the
right to marry just like anyone else
hashtag love wins again this is from the
app POTUS handle that the president just
got what earlier this year yes and so
this is another win for the president
she follows Hillary Clinton who of
course tweeted out her support right
away
Paul as you go through the actual
decision were you surprised by anything
that you've seen so far was there any
mention that you had not expected within
the within the writing you know I'm not
trying to boast here but no I wasn't
terribly surprised I think this is the
logical outcome of a movement in the
federal judiciary capped off by the
Supreme Court that's been underway for
some years the speed of that movement is
doubtless surprising in only a decade
we've gone from a consensus that the gay
marriage as hell
upheld by the Constitution is sort of a
fantasy to it being a hard reality so
that is is surprising if you go back ten
years but in terms of the last few years
no this the United States Supreme Court
put us on this path several years ago
and now we've reached the logical
destination we wanted to get your
thoughts on the popular the power of
popular opinion and how that influences
obviously the Supreme Court in this
particular case but just generally
speaking the fact that public opinion
now is so strong on a variety of issues
and that that message can be delivered
quickly instantly and consistently does
that have an effect on the
decision-making process I think it does
in in some instances and I think gay
marriage is one of those instances as
recently as just a few weeks ago Justice
Ruth Bader Ginsburg at some type of
public symposium was commenting on this
phenomenon when she was asked why did
attitudes toward homosexuality and in
particular gay marriage change so
quickly and she said because it was a
very short period of time when people
all across society realized I know gay
people they're my neighbors they're my
children and their aspiration to marry
does not seem remarkable to me it seems
like the most ordinary in a sense almost
a conservative impulse to formalize
relationships into marriage and I think
that process of of the popular consensus
forming has affected the United States
Supreme Court and I think that's helps
explain the speed that we've seen that
the court turn around in this issue over
the last decade you know what I want to
bring back Phil Mattingly into this
conversation because Phil as Jeff was
telling us earlier companies have really
been leading the way here the Supreme
Court has now played you could argue
some catch up to public opinion here
within the GOP presidential candidates
that they are struggling to define
themselves on this issue and very much
looking forward to put themselves past
it having said all that who within the
GOP is not necessarily most embracing
but least resistant to same-sex marriage
I think you have to be careful with this
because anybody use their public
statements matter and their public
statements are universal across the
field that they are opposed to same-sex
marriage I think there's a lot of
there's a lot of behind-the-scenes
thought about one campaign that might be
more open to it than others but I think
publicly everybody is more or less in
the same place the difference will be
who is willing to actively go out and
try and challenge this we just got a
statement from Bobby Jindal that is very
strong in its opposition saying that
this is an assault on religious liberty
that's along the lines I think you're
gonna see from Ted Cruz as well people
you won't see that from I think just in
general that tone are people like Jeb
Bush maybe some of the other top-tier
candidates Chris Christie folks like
that
I think scarlet what's most interesting
and this was just pointed out business's
role in this matters to the Republican
Party business's role in some of the
anti-discrimination laws when you talk
about on the state level in Indiana in
Louisiana business was just as effective
piece and a piece of this coalition on
same-sex marriage as anybody else they
have played a huge role along with
groups like the Human Rights Campaign
people like that who and actually making
this happen business obviously their
natural Alliance generally is with the
Republican Party this is an issue that
they absolutely brake on if you look at
businesses who filed supportive briefs
to this case there are a lot of them but
I think also importantly scarlet if you
look at there was a large group of top
Republican operatives that also filed in
support of same-sex marriage during this
process so it's not the party on the
whole scarlet but at this moment at
least in this time for the 13 declared
Republican candidates and the three that
are likely to get in over the next two
or three months the calculation is that
it's not worth getting out in front of
where their primary voters are well done
all right I want to thank you very much
Phil Mattingly oh all right we're gonna
just work you know Paul in that sense
you've been highlighting a lot of the
opinion I'm running is it also we're a
little bit of a reflection of the power
of Justice Kennedy in swinging a vote
one way or the other I mean is he become
that pivotal vote justice Kennedy has
been that pivotal vote on a number of
issues for a number of years sometimes
he tends to tilt the 5-4 decision in the
conservative direction that's been the
case for example on the First Amendment
when it encounters regulations such as
campaign finance in many cases related
to racial relations affirmative action
and so forth he's been in firmly on the
conservative side but in connection with
individual liberty particularly the
intimate relations and marriage he has
been consistently now a leader on the
Supreme Court in shaping the idea of why
the court must clear the way for gay
marriage and some of his language here
is as as high-flying and almost poetic
as you're going to find in a Supreme
Court decision